[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen micro
fällt meine lieben freunde wir dürfen
gar nicht lange zeit verlieren denn in
der letzten episode habe ich euch ja
gefragt mensch hat die irgendwo einen
anhaltspunkt gesehen irgendwas in die
richtung
luca da musst du hin damit du nach hause
findest und du bist in der hölle da und
da reingegangen deswegen musste jetzt in
die richtungen
so wurde mir nicht geschrieben wurde
etwas viel einfacheres geschrieben denn
luca macht mir einfach ein kompass und
ihr seht schon dass ich das gerade
gemacht haben der kompass zeigt hier
vorne in die richtung dementsprechend
müssen wir hinten hinlaufen ich der
definitiven bot brauchen und daher noch
mal kurz hierhin zurück und einen
botschaften deswegen meine lieben
freunde auf jeden fall eine riesiges
riesiges dankeschön an euch
ich weiß ich kenne minecraft seit zehn
elf jahren und müsste das eigentlich
wissen dass so was mit dem kompass
natürlich geht allerdings habe ich viele
sachen einfach vergessen über die zeit
deswegen jetzt einmal eine riesig lange
time lab wieder zurück zu unserer insel
hoffentlich fahren
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon wieder zu
hause angekommen hier sieht rechts die
kirche eingeblendet ihr seht hier vorne
dass die moderne strandvilla die wir in
der nächsten folge bis zum weiterbauen
werden hier sieht er hinten auf den
leuchtturm und hier vorne
auch das portal schwert im hintergrund
und darum soll es heute auch ein
bisschen gegen meine lieben freunde denn
dieses portal schwert sieht irgendwie
nur an unserer oberwelt pool aus und
noch nicht im netz
denn im never wisst ihr ja da haben wir
tausende treffen uns immer hoch gebaut
das ding steht da inmitten der luft
dieses komische portal
deswegen wurden hier unter einem in den
kommentare geschrieben luca bau doch
auch mal im netz ein schwert allerdings
nicht so ein schwert was hier vorne
irgendwie so pass
[Musik]
greven
serge erheben
ich wollte im scharfen kurzen klaps
geben dafür dass sich die ganze zeit
hier
pausenlos beleidigt werde ich habe
stundenlang war ich weg und ich komme
wieder und die ecke was sollen wir
machen freunde ich packe hier vorne erst
mal ganz kurz das hammelfleisch rein und
lager auch hier vorne das holz was wir
gerade nicht benötigen die sonne da
hinten geht schon wieder unterrichten
nehmer ganz kurz neben die wolle mit von
dem schaf das ist doch echt wieder nicht
war ich packe mal ganz kurz das boot
eben auf der anderen seite das tut mir
unfassbar leid ich weiß es das schaffen
riesenteil von diesem projekt war
allerdings ich wollte es auch einfach
nicht töten ist nicht da ich wollte im
kurzen klaps geben ich habe dem schafft
auch immer mal ab und an auch weizen
gegeben
damit zahlt mehr leben hat damit man
solche sachen halt irgendwie machen kann
das war wirklich real tod nicht gewollt
gerade also ich weiß gerade ehrlich
gesagt nicht was ich machen soll
schreibt mir gerne und in die kommentare
es tut mir einfach wirklich leid
ja dieser leuchtturm ist so schön da die
sonne allerdings gerade schon untergeht
würde ich sagen wie ich mal direkt
schnell schlafen und während ich schlafe
blende ich euch mal ganz kurz dieses
foto ja ein
das habe ich nämlich in der letzten
folge vergessen und zwar ist das der
schweiz abdruck von meinem unterarm auf
dem schreibtisch erfreulich ist
wahrscheinlich hält eklat vom zeigt uns
dass ich wollte eigentlich in der
letzten folge zeigen weil es da halt
passiert ist allerdings
ich glaube die lupo hast mich nachdem
ich jetzt das schaf außer sie ihn
umgebracht habe ich hab das in der
letzten folge hat leider vergessen mit
dem einblenden des fotos von meinem
unterarm deswegen habe ich gerade noch
mal kurz gezeigt und ihr seht doch schon
ich laufe jetzt gerade mal kurz rüber
denn ich muss hier meinen ganzen
schwarzen bisschen beraten
denn für unsere strandhaus villa
benötigen wir ja nicht die normalen
quartz blöcke sondern die glatten quarz
blöcke die last sich allerdings ganz
hört sie kann ich nicht drin lassen ist
aber egal
der quartz es sollte auf jeden fall ein
bisschen beraten denn wir haben in der
zwischenzeit auf jeden fall eine menge
andere sachen auch zu tun
zunächst erstmal werde ich meine ganzen
items thema wein packen und dann werde
ich nun die stücke hier so anordnen ein
leder in die mitte so dass ich einen
rahmen bekomme und die schwarz
eichenholz brettert so anordnen so dass
ich zwei schwarz eichenholz falltüren
bekomme ich fange ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich luca warum machst du das
was bringt dir denn jetzt rahmen und
schwarzenholz falltüren was ein
komisches wort auch was für ein extrem
langes wort auch einfach das volumen in
die kommentare geschrieben und zwar
wurde mir geschrieben dass das dann so
aussieht wie ein teller mit einem stück
schokolade drauf ich habe das jetzt noch
nicht getestet ich hab mich da einfach
mal vertraut und das würde vielleicht
ganz gut in unsere strandhaus wieder
passen beziehungsweise hier vorne auf
unseren tisch wo wir eigentlich diese
druckplatte haben das sollte eigentlich
ein teller darstellen also den rahmen
hin und die eichen schwarz eichenholz
druckplatte das ist rotes nice vor allem
in kombination mit den bechern und so
mit der schublade ich kann das ja auch
drehen noch ne machen wir mal so es die
echten als aus also danke für den
hinweis auf jeden fall wofür ich mich
auch noch bedanken wollte war erst mal
ganz kurz kann man das hier fordert
gewachsen
das sieht auch ganz okay aus wir werden
das hier auch heute wären das glaube ich
nicht schaffen dass sie ein bisschen
weiter zu bauen macht man dann in der
nächsten folge wofür ich nicht
allerdings auch noch bedanken wollte war
die erinnerung daran dass ich ja die
seerosenblätter zum portal da hinten
noch bauen muss das werde ich auch noch
machen bevor wir allerdings in netter
gehen werde ich das erst machen denn
darauf muss ich mich erst mal ganz kurz
vorbereiten denn
ich werde heute wie ich ja bereits
gesagt habe das portal auch für die
mieterseite schön bauen
ich kann hier nicht her laufen ich bat
sie hier erst mal ganz kurz die falltür
man sieht nicht aus wie schokolade ein
bisschen ich beziehe erst mal ganz kurz
die falter dass ich weiß dass ihr das
schaf verstorben ist da wir müssen uns
irgendwas überlegen freunde es ist es
ist ein bisschen so wie wenn so nach
zehn jahren sein haustier stirbt
[Musik]
alter die kuh steht hier einfach neben
der ja ich war es ja über das grab von
der von dem schaf das verbiete ich mir
ihr seht schon ich habe hier unsere neue
diamant spitzhacke mir gerade gemacht
denn ich hatte hier oben in der kiste
noch ein glück 1 buch das habe ich
darauf verzaubert ist zwar nur block
eins werden auf die anderen glück 3 die
müssen wir dann mal wieder reparieren
allerdings hab ich grad 20 level das
trägt damit nicht hin von daher eine
ganz kurze time jetzt nicht mehr erst
mal auch eine menge obsidian hole
[Musik]
so freunde ich bin fertig und ready to
go für unsere höllen mission heute ich
hab mir auch hier zwei neue re
seerosenblätter mitgenommen sodass wir
hier dann spannen drüber köpfen können
die sache ist jetzt allerdings dass ich
hoffentlich in dieser stadt nicht
angegriffen
jetzt ist er tot die sache ist jetzt
dass ich hoffentlich auf der einen seite
genügend obsidian mit habe und auf der
anderen seite dass ich es genau so
hinkriege wie hier
ich habe gerade noch mal ein bisschen
ins gedächtnis gerufen wie man ein
portal hier aussieht und es ist
schlimmer als erwartet
ich muss hier erstmal die ganzen
schwarzen nummer kurz abbauen
[Musik]
so sieht das ganze hier vorne jetzt aus
ich habe hier vorne jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen platz gemacht den turm i
hab ich mir gerade selber hingebaut mir
hier soll das gerüst zu schaffen dahin
auf dem könnten herumreiten allerdings
habe ich gerade die wir warten
angelruten craxi sache nicht dabei den
ihr euch dennoch ab allerdings habe ich
auch gesehen dass sich die hälfte meines
portals deutschen abgebaut habe ich
werde jetzt auch erstmal wieder ganz
kurz die fackel in die andere hand
nehmen sie das alles ein bisschen heller
ist und mein ob sillian nehmen und das
ganze hier erweitern dafür brauche ich
allerdings ganz kurz doch mal ne direct
ich werde das ganze nämlich erweitern
auf einen 3 block breites portal wir
haben ja gerade zwei blog breit
dementsprechend werde ich das ganze
jetzt einmal so machen und das hier so
runterziehen so dass es quasi ein
blocken breiter ist dass die ich jetzt
erstmal bis hier vorne runter und das
hier auch und jetzt kümmern wir uns erst
mal darum dass ich das hier abbauen
und jetzt werde ich mich quasi von unten
nach oben hoch bauen also quasi von der
schwert spitze hier unten liegen noch
eine menge dreck und obsidian blöcke ich
werde mich von der schwert spitze hier
unten hoch bauen bis zum
allerdings bzw das stimmt gar nicht ich
werde erst mal ganz kurz das hier vorne
so ein bisschen stört mich nicht so ein
bisschen schöner drumherum bauen und
dass man hier halt wirklich denkt dass
das portal hier vorne drin steht also
irgendwie so um die ecke rum und dann
hier vorne auch noch sagt
und es ist so dass man wirklich denkt
das portal kommt hier vorne raus das
hier mache ich auch mal zwei blöcke eben
so dass man hier auch keinen verdacht
schöpft es sollte wirklich so aus als ob
das portal hier aus der decke rauskommt
und hier von der anderen seite wollen
wir das auch noch mal eben kurz ein
bisschen zu und jetzt müssen wir nur
kurz die mitte des portals ausfindig
machen ich glaube dass das hier ist von
der airbase jetzt hier drei blöcke hoch
und entfernen nun diesen blog und
ersetzte ihn durch eine schwarz
steinmauer und entfernen den unteren
blocken ersetzten ihn durch eine kette
das soll quasi die spitze des portals
seien diese glocke können jetzt auch
kurz wegnehmen und hierauf setzen wir
nun zwei polierte schwarz stein ziegel
und auf den oberen von beiden seiten
eine treppe in die richtung ich habe
euch natürlich wieder das woran ich mich
also ein bisschen orientiert habe und in
die beschreibung gepackt ich pause
allerdings ein bisschen anders
ich möchte nämlich ein bisschen holz
dann haben weil wir hier auf seinem im
wald sind und so das ist dann glaube ich
ein bisschen cooler und ich brauche auch
ein bisschen größer weil mein schwert ja
in der oberwelt auch ein bisschen größer
ist hier vorne bei euch dann allerdings
so weiter mit den schwarz steinen ziegel
mit dem polierten schwarzen ziegeln so
auf jeden fall und dann kommt hier vorne
auch wieder eine treppe daran auf beide
seiten hier vorne auch zack und zaki
können das ganze natürlich zu bauen wie
er wollte ja auch noch eine ganz kurze
treppe und jetzt nehmen wir zwei
gemeißelte polierte schwarz stellen die
wir einmal hier reinpacken und auch hier
vorne an den rand kommen dann jeweils
eine schwarz steinmauer links und rechts
und auf diese treppen setzen jetzt neue
treppen nämlich zwei in die richtung 2
in die richtung und dann noch an jede
treppe dran
quasi eine die wieder so nach unten
zeigt das findet sich ja überall in
meiner welt wieder das habe ich bei den
häusern gemacht bei den dachgiebel quasi
und das soll sich jetzt auch hier im
schwert in der hölle wiederfinden so
dass das ganze von vorne dann nehme ich
mein ganzes leben dem netzwerk weg das
ist von vorne quasi so aussieht und nun
können
wir auch diese drei blöcke ich hier
nochmal kurz abbauen und ersetzen durch
obsidian nämlich 123 dann hier vorne
obsidian darauf hier obsidian drauf und
wir ziehen jetzt quasi von hier hoch an
den seiten so dass wir hier vorne oben
wieder ankommen da haben wir auf jeden
fall richtig gezählt sagt zack zack das
klappt ich könnte jetzt schon das portal
anzünden dann würden wir in unsere welt
kommt das mache ich allerdings zum ende
denn ich möchte das hier genau so bauen
wie ich das auch in unserer welt gemacht
habe nämlich mit immer schwarz steinmaur
es jetzt falsch platziert hier eine
schwarz steinmauer dann wieder hoch hat
er mich gesehen oder dann wieder hier
eine mauer und dann dazwischen ketten
platziert das machen wir jetzt von jeder
seite und noch hier hier hier und hier
so haben wir nun von beiden seiten
fertig und können das portal jetzt
anzünden das problem ist nur dass ich
jetzt natürlich kein feuerzeug
mitgenommen habe wie komme ich denn
jetzt aus der halle raus ich habe keine
ahnung und das was ich mir vorstelle
jetzt klappt allerdings werde ich erst
mal ganz kurz das wasser platzieren das
geht aber nicht jetzt nehme ich mir hier
einen lover aber mit und werde jetzt den
wir stil das ist ja glaube ich habe
gerade mal geguckt ob ich nicht noch
andere volkswirtschaft ist allerdings
leider nicht der fall
den werde ich jetzt auf jeden fall
schien eben platzieren hier und werde
jetzt lava wie mache ich ihnen das ich
werde mal ganz kurz denn hier glaube ich
abbauen
dann kann ich nämlich die lava hier
einsetzen so und jetzt werde ich mal ich
hier anstatt der treppe einen wir stil
platzieren dann nehme ich den hier vorne
auch mal ganz kurz weg und jetzt könnte
es ja eventuell klappen ich weiß ja
nicht ob diese teile anfangen zu brennen
allerdings dass das hier anfängt zu
brennen dann das rüber geht auf portal
oder ich hab noch einen schwarzen zorn
kann man das arm und vielleicht weil der
hier brennt ja augenscheinlich nicht ich
bin aber auch wieder so ein dooley dass
ich dann einfach das wichtigste
vergessen einfach ein verdammtes
feuerzeug um das portal anzuzünden
ich dachte halt ich nehme halt immer
irgendwie holz mit und immer irgendwie
keine ahnung was aber da da habe ich da
nicht dran gedacht das geht wirklich
nicht
mir bleibt nichts anderes übrig außer er
zu sagen freunde wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann das gerne einen daumen hoch
unserem video da abonniert main kanal
und klickt auf die glocke das hier ist
mein portal schwert es sehr deutlich
geiler aus wenn es an wäre und ich
dementsprechend auch zurück in meine
welt könnte allerdings nicht glaube ich
wieder gefangen im netz
wir haben keine andere möglichkeit außer
unser anderes portal zu suchen und dann
wieder über den umweg zurückzukommen
ich hätte zwar genug obsidian für noch
ein neues portal allerdings kann ich das
dann wieder nicht anzünden
also wenn ihre tipps habt schreibt gerne
und in die kommentare
und dann sehen wir uns übermorgen wieder
wenn es wieder heißt minecraft fehlen
mir gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]